if I had been able to sue sky fog for
finishing the Pope I would have had to
then write a chapter about the Daniel
Craig who was a super bond and I think
has guaranteed another 50 years of
franchise great music track Adele's song
which is bond
music it's because bees back to the John
Berry style of it's not stealing from
John Berry but your mayor this is a Bond
film well I think I think people missing
a very deal with that so they're you
know someone who said on an interview
this morning they're waiting for their
you can see it on IMAX to see Skyfall I
think I didn't think you lose a lot of
scope with the television screen all
those little screens are getting larger
there is no clarity
I don't think there is anything quite
the ability dressing up more people
dress down no cost well I didn't like
everybody sitting having your lunch and
dinner around me at popcorn rustling
oh I think I think violence and spirits
become pornography actually I don't
think they they have to be they're
violent I think it's the one tries to
outdo the other and also a little too
much fantasy me steel man
rates that like good old-fashioned
romantic comedies Cary Grant boobies the
epitome of sophistication you people say
you're Cary Grant or David Niven but
carries humor was completely
scatological he loved whoopee cushions
and little hand and he just adored all
that sort of thing he'd be like Blake
Edwards I think it's exciting sometimes
with an audience to see their
anticipation of a joke that's coming up
or a piece of action and then a shock
horror remember particularly the
audience reaction when the parachute
opens and becomes the Union flag of
England didn't matter what country it
saw it in there was a clause in
countries that had like English during
the few
the scarlet fever